all right let's start with survival
survival
so
do you guys have a survival plan i guess
is the first thing right
i remember when um this whole beer bug
thing
kicked off a couple years ago i can't
believe it's almost been two years now
it's gonna be what two years in december
january
two years i've been milking this mofo
anyway so beer bug kicks off a couple
years ago
and there was this like general feeling
um with most people and a lot of guys
that i talked to that um you know like
this was like a hit the fan sort of
event that's what
that's what we were led to believe
anyway like that's what we kept hearing
um people were
people were cleaning out the store
shelves and of all things what did they
clean out toilet paper
tp
tp toilet paper that's what that's what
they cleared off the shelves not
tin goods like beans
not ammo
toilet paper
that just goes to show you the state of
the vast majority of the population and
what they're thinking is if this if this
beer bug hits
do i have enough
toilet paper to wipe my
butt with
that's what they're thinking
so that just goes to show you how
unprepared most of the population is
because that's where their heads at they
don't they don't think clearly it's like
okay do you have food and water right
you know do you have
can you can you can you produce your own
water do you have the ability to eat
over a prolonged period of time a couple
months at least right i mean some people
there's some serious preppers out there
man like i've i've seen some serious
preppers that have like
bunkers stash with
six months worth of tinned and pickled
and preserved food
and they're just like they're ready for
it man like they are going to be the
most prepared
during the decline of the west i don't
think it's going to be an overnight
thing for it to be an overnight thing it
really has to be like a collapse of the
financial system it has to be like uh
what do they call in that movie an
extinction level event l-e-e-l-e
meteor comet hitting the earth you know
wiping out a good chunk of the
population
but um
yeah like we're mostly talking from the
perspective here of
how
bad policies and the general theme of
the western population votes and decides
to spend their time
and it's on dumb stuff
wokeness rainbows
inclusivity for everybody have as many
abortions as you want
you know never mind your personal
freedom and choices you know it's it's
my buddy it's my buddy my choice if it's
got to do with uh terminating a
pregnancy but if you don't want to take
a job then no sorry it doesn't count you
have to take the job otherwise you lose
your job right
so we talked about a lot of this stuff
in the last show i'm not going to go
over at all but if you want to see it
it's uh the prior episode uh tua number
nine you can go check it out this stuff
is available on podcast form too so you
can get it off
itunes google play blah blah blah all
that stuff it's all out there so you can
listen to this too
um
so survival
really boils down to
shelter and food would be the main
things
all right thriving is a totally
different thing but we're talking about
just basic right food and shelter
food water and shelter
and most people don't have a plan for
that
right like we take for granted that we
get up
and we have access to water that comes
out of a faucet but what happens
i mean if they're if they're jamming
jabs down our throat right now what
happens if they jam some new thing in
the water system i mean fluoride in the
water system ain't particularly good for
you but they've been cramming that down
our throats
if you don't have a reverse osmosis
water filtration system
or some kind of filtration system that
gets rid of the crap that's in the city
lines you're going to run into problems
you want to talk about crap in the study
lines i had my water filters changed the
other day in my system and it was black
it was like this shitty brown
burnt like
rust color it was just nasty as
survival matters man most people
don't have a plan for it
that's you know it's like a
you know it's like a serious thing you
know
what happens if policing disappears what
happens if um you know you don't have
access to
safe reliable everything not a lot of
people think about that you know they
just they just believe that this is
always going to be here they just
believe that you know if
your neighbor's house is on fire
they're going to be able to pick up
something like this
and turn it on and it'll connect to a
cell tower and then they can call a
number
where people will answer and say what
can i do to help you and then send you
know 30 brave men in a bunch of fire
trucks with hoses to put the whole thing
out you take that for granted
right
what if that doesn't work what if the
cell tower doesn't work what if there's
no fire services what if there's no
policing
the thing that makes me laugh the most
is when people just defund the police oh
yeah
that's gonna solve your problems today
in it
defund the police we don't need them
but that's hey listen you know the fact
that you hear this stuff like this so
often and
nobody like destroys it like quashes it
so quickly like are you insane like what
are you thinking like really you want to
get rid of policing you want to defund
the police
really
you know the fact that nobody says
anything again it's telling telling
other times right
so you have your survival sorted out
this isn't part of the enjoy part i'm
going to get to the enjoy part because
you know the enjoy part is kind of
interesting
i got some black hat
one of my guys came up with and i think
uh if i'm not mistaken i think aaron
cleary talked about one of his um
we call it operation evil or something
like that which is kind of tied into my
buddy's black hat stuff
but um yeah i'll go over that too
anyway location
listen if you want to enjoy the decline
being in a urban
coastal city
toronto new york
l.a
chicago's on a big ass lake you know all
that like all of these
large
urban coastal like six 10 12 million
people living in these cities i mean
there's cities out there that more than
that too obviously but you get the idea
like
is
is that what like how like a place that
you're gonna enjoy the decline you don't
have the ability to maneuver
show me your paperwork if you want to
come into this restaurant and sit down
watch a movie in the theater you know
what's it going to be next you know make
sure your paperwork's updated with
stamps for all your daily pills that
pfizer you know is gonna make you take
sort of thing
right
so you want some flexibility and freedom
it ain't gonna come from large urban
centers okay
there's
i'm just going to say it because because
i've noticed it because i hold real
estate in downtown toronto
there's an exodus of people leaving
large cities the smart ones have
either exited or they're planning an
exit
hey
you know these these are the smart
people right they're you know they're
the leaders there's a reason why the
moves are being made for those personal
freedoms you're not gonna get it in an
urban city
right
location does matter
government in location matters too
everybody talked about my plan to exit i
don't know if it's going to be permanent
or on a part-time basis canada find a
place that's
more don't i don't have to deal with the
wokeness i don't have to deal with the
incredibly high tax rates i don't have
to deal with the cold ass winners i
don't have to deal with you know all of
that stuff
or or if i do have to deal with it it's
on a
very limited basis right there's places
in the caribbean with very low or if no
tax rates there's places around the
world that you know exists like that
there's places where
they don't entertain
wokeness you know
freaking
justin trudeau gave a speech in the last
couple weeks some of you may have heard
of it i'm sure many of you didn't hear
it because a lot of you live outside of
the country
but he said something like
we need to come out of this
she session
for the she economy
doesn't say economy doesn't say
recession it's all about the wokeness
and trying to lean into all the nonsense
so if you're finding yourself in an
environment where the location doesn't
allow you to enjoy the decline
you're not you're not tied down there
right
um i did a cast with this guy david
lesperance
and it was on my plane to win series in
the last few months you can go back and
check it out
you can just search on my channel
entrepreneurs and cars and then david
les bronze
and he's a
he's a former lawyer that specializes in
relocating
uh individuals high net worth
individuals you know specifically uh
right now anyway
uh to other locations in the world where
their tax rates are more favorable
they're treated better you know they can
get basically what they want in their
life and there's a lot of things that
came out of that one of the things that
really stood out is your is your assets
don't need to be where your asses right
so i mean you can live somewhere and
have your assets another country
um there's there's lots of things to
consider having more than one passports
a really good idea
we talked about that during that show in
detail so you can check that out
on why
um but yeah your your location is it's
not fixed guys you know this is not
you know 20 000 years ago where you know
you couldn't hop on a plane or get in a
car and drive you know i mean freaking a
car you can drive almost
1000 kilometers a day easily right
comfortably you know for the most part
um hopping on a plane you can cover a
lot more than that way quicker boats too
i mean you know not not quite as quick
obviously but you have the ability to
maneuver so don't think for a second
that just because you live somewhere
that you need to be there for the rest
of your life if you think
that it doesn't serve you you can move
on yeah the she economy the balance
sheet balances itself trudeau
we've got an election coming out soon
can't wait for this one to wrap up
hopefully we get rid of this clown
you